good evening everybody can everybody
hear me yes my name is Jeffrey West and
I'm on the faculty at the Santa Fe
Institute and I had the great honor
until about a year or so ago being
president and I also have the honor of
introducing the speaker for the last of
the UM lectures you are all presumably
familiar with the fact that every year
we put on this series of elam lectures
where we invite a distinguished speaker
to talk in a subject that we think is of
a general interest but also talk about
it in some depth over three evenings and
this is the last of those three and I
presume that most of you have been here
the other two but I will repeat some
things just to make sure everybody's
sort of speak on the same page our
distinguished lecturer is is indeed
distinguished it's Mark Newman sitting
down in the front him you were here
again in a few minutes mark is very well
known to the Santa Fe Institute
community he's well known actually
within this community because he has
given a public lecture in the regular
public lecture series but he's
internationally known for the work about
what she's been talking namely this kind
of revolution in thinking about many
problems in terms of network structures
and network dynamics mark was he
graduated he got his doctorate from
Oxford and after Oxford spent a couple
of years in a postdoctoral position at
Cornell and before moving to the Santa
Fe Institute where he was a research
professor and when it came time to move
on he moved to the University of
Michigan in the physics department at
the University of Michigan associated
with there also with their complex
systems Institute and there he's had a
rapid rise
I don't know the exact title I know it's
the the dirac professor but he's a
university professor basically at the
University of Michigan he's had an
incredibly successful career with
tremendous impact especially in this
area to do with networks and the
important thing about that is that it's
very much in the Santa Fe Institute
tradition of it's not some narrowly
defined field but it is something that
has implications that you've heard about
in the last couple of nights but you'll
hear much more of I think tonight in
terms of its impact on fields stretching
across the whole spectrum actually of
science and technology and Mark will
just touch on a few but it's as I say
it's very much in the center of an
institute tradition because the Santa Fe
Institute was set up and indeed
practices the idea that there many of
the most interesting fascinating and
urgent problems facing science and
society today are ones that require very
broad thinking across multi disciplines
and are very often to do with systems
that we call complex everything from
questions in biology questions of
ecology questions of social organization
questions of economics and markets all
of these have this highly complex
character of many agents interacting
with one another giving rise to
extraordinarily complex quote behavior
with a phenomena that encompasses many
scales both in space and time things
happen on very short times but also
happen on very long times they have been
in short distances and long distance all
interacting together and these are some
of the most challenging problems and the
development of thinking about these
things in terms of networks whether it
is within the cell within an organism
within an urban organization within
markets within social interactions this
has been an extraordinary tool in coming
to terms
with not only the understanding in
qualitative and quantitative terms but
taking that understanding into a
predictive framework and mark has been
certainly one of the great leaders in
this internationally recognized as such
and we're absolutely delighted that he
agreed to give these lectures and come
back to Santa Fe and give us a big
overview of some of the exciting things
that are going on in that field and to
which he's made major contribution so
with that I'll turn it over to mark
thank you very much Jeffrey for that
nice introduction hello everyone so just
in case you didn't make it to the
previous two lectures let me start off
by giving you a brief rundown of what we
talked about so forth so this the topic
is networks as Jeffrey mentioned this is
the last of these three olam lectures in
the previous lectures we talked about
first of all what is a network it's a
bunch of dots joined together by lines
we call the dots nodes for lines edges I
will use those words frequently the
reason we're interested in networks is
because they can be used to describe all
sorts of things in the world
as Jeffrey mentioned things like
technological networks like the Internet
information networks like the World Wide
Web biological networks like food webs
social networks which link people
together in various ways and then last
night we talked about once we know about
these networks what can we do with them
what can we understand better and I give
you a bunch of examples of things that
we can say for instance we can talk
about the idea of centrality which
answers questions like which are the
most important nodes in a network which
is the most important website which is
the most important person in a social
network transitivity the idea that if
you have two friends then they're quite
likely to be friends of each other as
well by virtue of the fact that they
have you as a common friend and we can
use this fringe instance to predict who
will be friends in future people who
don't know each other yet but have a
common friend are likely to become
friends we talked about homophony the
idea that people tend to be friends with
others who are similar to them in some
whay and modularity the idea that
networks divide into these groups and we
can use this for instance to predict how
networks will split and then reform so
all of these are very important central
ideas in the study of networks and very
useful in many practical circumstances
but they're also limited in that these
are all questions about sort of static
properties of networks think of the
network is just I've taken a snapshot of
it here it is this is the network it's
fixed and now I'm going to calculate
something about it however many of the
things that we're interested in about
networks concern dynamics things
changing on networks in fact there are
two ways really that we can look at
dynamics on that works one is cases
where the network itself is changing so
nodes can be appearing and disappearing
edges can be appearing and disappearing
and the other is that the network can be
fixed or not changing very much but
there can be something dynamical going
on on the network for example a rumor
spreading through a social network or
something like that would be example of
a process taking place on a network so I
wanted to talk about these kinds of
ideas of how things change in dynamics
today I have to warn you that this is an
area which is not nearly as well
understood as some of these static ideas
that I talked about yesterday
there's many open questions concerning
dynamics on and of networks but there
are also some areas that we feel we
understand reasonably well so there's
some some specific cases were beginning
to make progress with a few specific
cases in understanding them and it's
those I'd like to talk about today so
the first example I want to give you
it'll this is going to end up taking you
in a variety of different things but I
want to start in a specific place and
talk about citation networks what is a
citation Network a citation network is a
network of documents so suppose I have
an example would be legal cases in this
country when a judge decides a legal
case they write an opinion to explain
their thinking and how they decided what
the what the verdict should be in the
case and often in fact virtually always
when they write their opinion they will
ie refer to previous opinions written by
other judges to establish precedent this
case was kind of like this other case
and so I took my thinking from that case
so now you have a network where the
nodes in the network are legal cases
legal cases legal opinions and the edges
connecting together are this opinion
cites refers to this other opinion
another example of a citation network
probably the most famous example is the
network of scientific papers when we
scientists discover something which we
think is exciting and other people would
like to know about it we write papers
about it to tell people to explain the
idea but usually in fact basically
always we're basing idea our ideas we're
building off things that other
scientists have done in the past
so we cite ie refer to previous papers
that those other people have done in
order to give credit the people who came
up with the ideas that we're building on
so here's a paper of mine for example if
you turn to the end of your typical
scientific paper there is a bibliography
which says you know these are all the
other papers that I based this work on
and you can look at one of these papers
for instance this one here it gives a
reference what Journal and page I should
go look it in and you can go to the
library pull that volume off for the
shelves and find the paper that's
referring to so you can there's a
connection here from one paper to
another paper the nodes in the network
of the papers and the edges joined
together and this one cites this other
paper networks of scientific papers are
actually an interesting case there one
of the things that have been studied for
the longest this famous paper paper by
Derek Gisela Price was published in the
journal Science in 1965 that's oh here's
a picture of a citation network I'm
gonna skip over that here I want this
here's price so this is one of the kinds
of networks that we studied for the
longest I mentioned before that social
networks are probably the oldest example
of quantitative scientific study of
networks been studied since the 20 or so
30s but this one is getting close this
has been since the 1960s people have
been doing this about 50 years people
been studying these citation networks it
really started off with this guy here
his name is Jean Garfield he's still
alive I've met him a couple of times
nice guy what he was doing back in the
sixties is he was creating what we would
nowadays call
database of scientific papers that have
been published and who they cited which
ones cited which other ones I mean I
call it the database I don't think he
had a computer I think was probably just
a really big rolodex but anyway he was
he was assembling this database it
eventually became something called the
science Citation Index it still exists
to this day and very important tool that
scientists use every day and he had this
friend Derek de sóller price price was
an interesting character he was a
physicist by training he had a PhD in
physics but he ended up being more
interested in the history of science and
he became a professor of the history of
science at Yale University but he was he
had very white interests I mean he wrote
about all sorts of things not just the
history of science and amongst other
things he was interested in the patterns
of citations between scientific papers
so in new Garfield and he was able to
get a hold of a copy of this database
and he did some analysis on the database
and discovered a bunch of interesting
laws that seemed to govern the way
scientific publication goes and probably
the most famous of those laws is what he
did is he looked at how many times
papers get cited how many other people
referred to this scientific paper of
course there are some papers that
referred to a lot you know if it's a
paper by Einstein then referred to by
many other people and but there are
other papers which hardly get referred
to at all
so what he did was he looked at the
distribution of how many times papers
get cited and what he found was that
there are a lot of papers that only get
cited a small number of times and there
are a few papers out in the tail here
that get cited a large number of times
okay so this if you've been in the
previous lectures then this should be a
kind of familiar pattern actually this
is nothing other than what we called the
degree distribution of the network
previously remember we talked about a
degree of a node in the network as being
the number of connections it has well
the edges in this case are one paper
slighting another paper so the number of
connections that our paper has is just
the number of papers that cite it so
this number of citations you get is
nothing more than your degree in the
network and what we're talking about
here is the distribution of degrees we
talked about this for instance in the
case of the internet here but actually
this is a very common pattern you see
this long tail pick
where there's a lot of papers that get a
few references and there's a few papers
that get referenced very many times this
particular form as price showed follows
a mathematical rule called a power law
or a Pareto distribution very good so
this power law is actually kind of a
surprising thing it's not what we
normally expect to see and I'll explain
what I mean by that so take a look at
this plot on the left here this plot on
the left shows you know in principle
this is kind of a similar plot to this
one down here but it's for a different
thing this one is for the heights of
human beings actually male human beings
so this is heights of male human beings
from a recent survey expressed in
centimeters and what you see on this
plot is that there are almost no people
who have height below 150 centimeters
and almost no people who have height
above 200 centimeters and virtually
everybody actually is sort of in the
middle here around about 170 centimeters
which is about 5 foot 8 inches so what
we're saying is there's a very narrow
range of possible heights that people
have this is quite different from what
we see with the citations with the
citations there are some papers that are
get cited once and there are other
papers get cited a thousand times right
we don't see that with the heights of
people right there are people who are 6
foot tall but there aren't people who
are 6,000 foot tall right we don't see
the same range so there really is a huge
difference between what we're seeing in
the citations and what we're seeing in
most other things like heights of people
I just gave one other example over here
this is speeds of cars measured on the
highway so you see cars going at 40
miles an hour and you see cars going 100
miles an hour but you also see cars
going at a hundred thousand miles an
hour on the highway right so what we're
seeing here with the citations really is
a radically different thing from what
we're normally used to seeing in other
things that we look at so let's take a
look at some of the actual data on
citations or papers these are a recent
data they're not the 1960s data these
quite new now they're from the 1990s
this is a data set compiled by Sid
Redner it contains seven hundred and
eighty thousand papers about physics I
mean there are really a lot of papers
about
first thing to notice is that 368
thousand of them have never been sighted
at all
that's 47% so nearly a half of the
physics papers have never been cited by
and nobody has ever referred to them not
even the person who wrote them has ever
cited them so if you write a physics
paper in your psyche even once then
you're already in the top half of the
class then then if you also how many
papers got one citation well now it's a
goes down pretty quickly seventy
thousand two is 44,000 32 25 21
thousands go down pretty quickly but
there's this long tail if you go to all
the way down to the bottom you find that
there's one paper in this particular
dataset that got eight thousand nine
hundred and four citations that's the
long tail that's the hub that's the node
which has very many connections in the
networks very good so this may seem like
a slightly esoteric example you know you
know who really cares about citation
networks or scientific papers except
maybe some scientists but it turns out
that this kind of pattern this power law
or Pareto distribution is something that
we see in a bunch of other complex
systems that were already interested in
here's a whole set of examples of things
that also follow power laws so we've
seen citations but also for instance
word frequencies in any language there
are some words most words in fact which
only get used occasionally but there are
some words like and and ver they get
used all the time very frequently so
they're out in the tale web hits if you
look at how many people look at a web
page most web pages only a few people
look at them but there are a few web
pages like Yahoo or Google or CNN or
something
there are lots and lots of people okay
so they're out there the hub's out in
the tail people's wealth most people
have a moderate amount of money but
there's a small number of people you
know Bill Gates or whoever who have a
really stupendous amount of money
they're the ones out in the tail again
also name frequencies for instance so
most family names surnames are not very
common most of them are just a few
people with those names but they're a
small number names like Smith
lots of people have them populations of
cities most cities pretty small a few
cities la New York very big so there's a
whole bunch of things that we have here
that follow the same power law behavior
it's a distinctive and slightly
surprising thing and we see it in these
various different systems so what I'm
going to take a momentary detour just to
discuss these power laws for a moment
because this is really a fascinating
area in in complex systems these power
laws imply various things about the
systems they describe I just want to
give you one example of something that
you can do that you can calculate this
is something called the 8020 rule so
let's take the example of people's
wealth how much money people have so if
you so you know what not everybody has
the same amount of money some people
have less money some people have more
suppose I were to take the 10% of the
population that have the most money and
then ask what fraction of the total
money in the whole country does that top
10% have well it's not going to be 10%
it's going to be more than that because
these are not just average people from
the population these are the richest
people so they're going to have more
than 10% of the money so we can make a
plot like this one here horizontal axis
the fraction of the population so you
know what what fraction of the richest
people am I talking about and the
vertical axis is how much of the money
that they have so for instance I could
say I want to know about the top 20% of
the population that's point two here
follow the line up and across and it
tells me that about 86 percent of the
money is in the hands of the top 20
percent of the population the various
curves here
depend on the exact details of the
power-law behavior but that result there
20 percent have 86 percent of the money
is actually about right for the United
States it's true that about the richest
20 percent of the country have about 86
percent of the wealth and the remaining
14 percent of the wealth goes to
everybody else the bottom eighty percent
so this curve is sort of a measure of
the way the wealth is distributed across
people you can do similar calculations
for other things that follow power laws
for instance it turns out that ten
percent of the city's the biggest ten
percent of cities have sixty percent of
the people in them and the other forty
percent of the people live in all the
other cities put together
75% of people have surnames in the most
popular 1% of surnames just the top 1%
and the remaining 99% of all surnames
could account for just the remaining 25%
of the population so this curve is sort
of a measure of how skewed the
distribution is what a large fraction
live in the biggest cities or have the
most common surnames and so forth so
this is this itself these power laws are
a big area of study in complex systems
but I want to get back to the networks
we started talking about and ask a
slightly different question which is
well if we have these power laws in all
these things where does it come from
there are various theories about where
power laws come from but one of the
leading theories is the theory of
preferential attachment this is
something that price himself worked on
in the 1970s because he was interested
in these citation networks so let me
describe it in the language of prices
citation networks his suggestion was so
each paper published cites some number
of previously existing papers and his
proposal was that they cite previously
existing papers in proportion to the
number of people who cited those papers
before so this is a sort of rich get
richer phenomena it says if you lots of
people have already referred to your
paper then you're going to get more
citations and if very few people have
then you're not going to get very many
in a way this seems like a reasonable
thing because one of the main ways that
scientists find papers is that other
people cited them you know some somebody
referred to them you say oh I see this
person is referring to this paper I'll
go look at it and you go look at this
paper and you read it and maybe you get
some idea from it if that idea ends up
going into your work then maybe you cite
it too so paper is more likely to get
another citation if lots of people cited
in the past on the other hand this sign
that sounds a little unnatural in the
sense that it has absolutely nothing to
do with the content of the papers
doesn't matter what your paper is about
whether it's a good paper whether it's a
terrible paper right in this theory in
prices preferential attachment theory
it's all just a question of the rich get
richer
depends on how many citations you've had
in the past so that may seem a little
bit unrealistic but wait wait a bit well
we'll see what happens so price took
this seemingly simple theory and he gave
it this complete mathematical treatment
of it so you can calculate all sorts of
things in particular you could calculate
how many citations papers are going to
get so there was some math that went in
here and some formulas that come out at
the end we don't really care about
formulas what we really care about is
the picture this picture shows the
distribution of the number of citations
the papers get the number of times
they've been referred to and that's
that's the sort of purplish brown
circles in the background there and this
dotted line is the prediction of prices
theory so it really does pretty well
despite the fact that this is a theory
which totally ignores the actual content
of the papers right it's just assuming
that your paper gets cited because other
people have cited it in the past so this
is a nice theory but it turns out in
fact that you can do a lot more with
this than what price did so here's one
example of something else we can
calculate from his theory so we don't
bunch more mass than we get out some
more formulas and what this tells us is
the time evolution of the citation
Network so so right we're back to the
subject we started talking about at the
beneath the lecture now we wanted to
know about how the network evolves well
this network is evolving all the time
all the time people are publishing new
papers in those papers cite previous
papers and so forth so this is precisely
an example of a network that's evolving
over time and prices theory if it's
correct and it seems to be pretty good
tells us how this thing is evolving over
time so we can do some other
calculations and calculate for instance
the following we can calculate if a
paper is published at a particular time
how many citations do we expect it to
have by now and when we calculate that
the result looks like this so horizontal
axis time the beginning is you know the
beginning of the field whenever the
field started and the end is now the
present day so look at the black curve
first you'll notice that curve goes down
to zero at the present day that's
because a
that was published yesterday doesn't
have any citations yet nobody's cited it
because it's only just been published so
we expect the curve to go down to zero
there what's surprising is this huge
spike that you get as you go back in
time towards the beginning of the field
there's the papers that are published
early in a field have enormous Lemoore
citations there are referred to many
many more times than papers are
published late and remember that this is
nothing to do with their content because
content doesn't even come into this
theory so you might think that well in
that case this isn't a very good theory
but here again are the real data the
purple stuff in the background is the
real data for actual papers and the
agreements not perfect you know there's
some wobble there but it's pretty good
in fact this line pretty well predicts
the number of citations that real paper
so this is this is real papers now and
you see that there is this effect this
huge spike if you published a paper
right at the beginning of the field then
you get enormous Lemoore citations the
people who came along only a little bit
later this is something we call a first
mover advantage in this case Illustrated
for citation networks but it turns out
that this can apply to all sorts of
other things as well the basic thinking
behind the first mover advantage is the
following that if you're one of the
first people to publish a paper in a
field then somebody comes along after
you and publishes another paper they're
gonna have to cite you because you're
the only game in town there isn't
anybody else to cite so it may be that
your paper isn't very good and maybe
your paper isn't very relevant it
doesn't really matter you know only
three other papers have been published
on this subject and I have to cite
something so I'm gonna cite those ones
right so those early papers published in
field get a lot of citations just goes
to their very only game in town which
means they get an early lead over other
later papers and then this preferential
attachment effect kicks in and says the
guys who have the most citations they
get the most extra ones how many you get
depends on how many you have so once you
get that early lead this preferential
attachment thing amplifies it so that
you always have a lead and eventually
you're way out in front of everybody
else and it really doesn't matter what
you said in your paper or whether it was
relevant you still get that early lead
so none of this depends on the actual
content of the paper any questions and
and this is sort of supported to some
extent by the fact that the early
citations in a field are often between
relatively unrelated papers so in some
sense this is kind of a depressing
result it sort of tells us scientists
that that really what you need to do if
you want to be well sighted is that you
need to it's much better to write a
mediocre paper in tomorrow's hottest
field than it is to write a really good
paper in today's I I don't entirely
believe that I certainly believe that
there is an effect of paper quality here
in particular you know how do you get
that early lead the first one to get in
the lead well part of that is by writing
a paper that people actually pay
attention to and are interested in there
may be other things that work as well
and being early is certainly extremely
good I actually have a friend who who
tells me he exploited this idea so he
somebody told him about a new field that
was coming along we thought was really
exciting and he wasn't that interesting
it we said well I'm gonna write a paper
in his anyway because then it'll be one
of the first papers and now he tells me
apparently lots of people have referred
to it so so maybe you can use this so so
so and this matches the data very well
as they say so you know this is kind of
a slightly esoteric example this whole
citation you know who really cares about
how many citations paper gets maybe a
few scientists do but there's no real
reason why you should but as I say you
can apply this to other things as well
there was a really nice example of this
effect there's a guy called Duncan Watts
who used to be a postdoc at Santa Fe
Institute back in the 90s
he's now principal scientist at Yahoo
researched the Internet company and he
did a study of downloading music on the
Internet
so what he did for this study was he set
up a website where participants could
download music and the music was music
by relatively unknown bands who were
happy to donate their music because they
wanted the publicity so he set up this
website people could download this music
but the website was very simple and
didn't give you much information so all
it gave you
for eat so for each song that you could
download it gave you the name of the
band it gave you the name of the tune
and crucially it gave you how many
people had downloaded that particular
song before so given that these are
unknown bands and people can really have
any way of choosing which of the good
songs download which is bad songs
download it turned out that what a lot
of people did is they just went for the
ones that have been downloaded a lot
before they say oh I see this song has
been downloaded by a lot of other people
must be a good song I'm gonna listen to
that one as well so this is price
precisely this preferential attachment
effect the things that have more
downloads get more downloads so if for
whatever reason but it's precisely this
sort of amplification effect so what
indeed they found was that you end up
getting this power law this distribution
where most of the songs only got a small
number of downloads but there were a few
hubs out there in the tail that really
got a lot okay so maybe that isn't that
surprising but now they did a really
clever thing they lied about the number
of downloads
they changed the numbers so they didn't
actually reflect how many times those
songs have been downloaded before and
they still found that the ones with the
biggest numbers got downloaded the most
and ended up way out ahead of all the
others so this tells you this really
directly tells you that there's no
effects of the content of the songs or
whether they're good songs or bad songs
you can make any song the one that gets
out in the lead and has this huge
advantage over all the others all it has
to do is get a little early lead in the
downloading which you can give it give
to it for instance by lying and then and
then that'll be amplified by the
preferential attachment effects and end
up it'll end up getting you know
hundreds of downloads and you can do
this for any song so maybe this is sort
of telling people something that's
telling tell you that you know it
doesn't really matter if your product is
no good all you've got to arrange is for
it to get a little early lead over the
competition
and then this effect is gonna kick in
and you'll get way out ahead of
everybody else now to be fair one of the
ways that you can get that early lead is
to have a product that's actually good
and people like it but there are
probably other ways as well you know you
can have good advertising
right so so the the bottom line is
really all you need to do in order to
have a successful song or something like
that is to get that early lead and you
can do that however you want be it by
having a good song or any other way okay
very good so this is one example of a
network that is changing over time the
other the sort of flip side of this
dynamics is the question of networks
that stay fairly constant but there's
some dynamical process going on on the
network so I want to spend little time
talking about that other side of things
as well and I want to talk about one
particular example of a process that
goes on in networks it's one that I've
worked on quite a lot which is the
spread of disease over networks now I
talked about this a bit in the previous
lecture as well and it's obviously a
very important application of this
network theory thing so one of the
things that we've worked on is
understanding how the patterns of
connection between people affect the
spread of the disease so you're
interested in some particular disease
and here's this little picture you have
in your head you have some network of
people that connected together and one
of those people get sick represented by
this red node in the middle and then
that person can give the disease to
their friends and they can give them to
these to their friends and to their
friends and so forth so the disease
spreads over the network like this so
what this is telling you is if you want
to understand how the disease spreads
it's absolutely crucial to understand
what the structure of the network it's
different Network different spread of
disease this picture however is not
really entirely accurate this is rather
oversimplified picture what's really
happening is something more like this in
the real world you know if I get the flu
I don't necessarily give it to all of my
friends I might give it to some of them
but there are some others who won't
catch it from me it's not a hundred
percent certain that a person you know I
might not see some people this week or
if I do you know maybe I'm not sitting
close enough to them took off on them
and give them the flu so we can think of
this as modifying the network now some
of the network the edges are Bowl
here these black edges those represent
the ones where I actually saw that
person and I was sitting closer than
enough to them and so forth edges
sufficient to transmit the disease and
the gray ones represent all the others
these are the ones where you know maybe
I didn't see the person that week so now
what happens is if the person in the
middle gets sick they give the disease
to some of their neighbors but not
others this person over here escaped
getting the disease and then they pass
it on to other people and they pass it
on to other people you notice in the end
in fact this person did end up getting
sick but not from the first person the
disease had to go around another way so
this is a much more realistic picture of
a spread of disease on a network and in
fact this is the basic picture that a
lot of calculations of the spread of
disease on their work are based on but
the nice thing about this picture is
that really this network here is still
just a network if I just forget about
the gray edges here and just think about
this as being the black edges well
that's just a network cell the disease
is still just reading on it or he's not
the same network that I started off with
it's a different network I've modified
it a bit to allow for the fact that not
all of the edges transmit the disease
but it's still just some network and so
I still just have the disease spreading
on a network so actually I can account
for this idea that there's not a hundred
percent problem with your transmission
of the disease pretty easily just by
modifying my network appropriately this
kind of modification where I you know
color in some of the edges and not
others is called a percolation model and
that's one of the fundamental models
that's used in the mathematical study of
the spread of disease very good
so now the point is so we have this sort
of mathematical model that we can use to
simulate the spread of disease over the
network and now the point is we want to
understand how the structure of the
network is going to affect the spread of
disease because different shapes of
networks are going to make the network
disease spread in different ways and we
want to understand the connection
between the structure of network on
disparities so take for instance this
network here that we saw in the previous
lecture this is a network that came from
a study of the spread of tuberculosis
which is increasingly becoming a serious
health risk because of antibiotic
resistant strains
so what this network shows is the nodes
are people in the study and the edges
represent who's been in close physical
proximity with whom recently because
that's what you need in order to
transmit TB TB is transmitted by one
person coughing on another or sneezing
on another so you have to be close
together and what you see one of the
things you see when you look at this
network is that there are again some
hubs there are these nodes in the
network that have high degrees this is
again the long tail effect that we were
just talking about there's a small
number of nodes with a lot of
connections and you can certainly
imagine that that could have a
substantial effect on the spread of
disease for instance if this person in
the middle here got sick they could give
the disease to a lot of other people
that would be bad so now we say well
what properties is it of the network
that controls the way the disease
spreads if if you had to make a first
simple guess maybe the sort of thing you
would guess is well I guess that for
instance the average degree of a node is
an important thing remember the degree
is the number of connections you have
and if on average nodes have a lot of
connections then the disease is going to
spread relatively quickly and if on
average they only have a few it's not
going to spread so quickly so actually
that's a pretty shrewd guess that's
basically the right idea but it's
actually not exactly right it turns out
that it's not the degree of a person
that matters but the square of their
degree in other words take the degree
and multiply it by this by itself I can
give you the sort of hand waving
argument for why that is so consider
this person in the middle here again
they've got you know maybe a hundred
friends that means that if they get sick
there's a hundred people they could
spread the disease onto so it's a
hundred times more effective at
spreading disease but this person here
is also a hundred times more likely to
get the disease in the first place
because they've got a hundred friends
right there are a hundred people they
could catch it from as well as a hundred
people they give it to so there are
hundred times more likely to catch the
disease and a hundred times more likely
to pass it on so there are a hundred
times a hundred ten thousand times more
effective at spreading the disease that
the person who only has one contact so
it's the square of the degree that
matters and what that means is that the
hubs in the network have an enormous
influence in fact in many cases they are
the primary driving force that affects
the way the network behaves a person who
has a thousand contacts is a million
times more effective at passing on this
disease than the person who only has one
so the hubs are really very important
let me show you a practical example of
that in action this is real data from
the spread of SARS severe acute
respiratory syndrome which is a viral
form of pneumonia that made the news a
lot in about 2002 2003 when there was a
big outbreak of it in Southeast Asia
these are data from the outbreak they
had in Singapore where they have very
good data about who caught the disease
from whom this is from a study that was
done by Steve Bugatti what these data
show is here's where the outbreak
started was patient number one and
unfortunately patient number one was a
hub in the network so they passed the
disease on to many other people most of
those people are just ordinary regular
people in the network nothing special
about them they don't have that many
contacts so most of them didn't pass it
on to anybody else or maybe pass it on
to one other person and then it would
have died out so the disease would have
died out right there and then if it
hadn't been for the fact that one of the
people the person one passed it on to
was another hub that gives it another
big boost again the disease would have
died out because most of the people
number six passed it on to also didn't
pass it on to anybody else but one of
them was another hub another big boost
and so forth and so what you can see is
these hubs are solely responsible for
keeping the disease alive right if it
was just all the regular people with
only a few contacts their disease will
just die it died out but these hubs even
though they're very small in number are
extremely effective at passing the
disease along and if so they're
essentially solely responsible for
keeping the infection alive if they were
not there the disease would die out very
quickly
well this then maybe gives us another
idea what if we could get rid of just
those few hubs in the network if we
could just get rid of them then the
disease wouldn't be able to spread and
it would die out so this leads us to
think about the
idea of vaccination of populations
removing notes from the network you
could so one of the ways to prevent the
spread of a disease is to vaccinate
people if you have a vaccine right when
you vaccinate people you are effectively
removing those people from the network I
mean of course they're still there in
the network but as far as the disease is
concerned they're not there anymore
because the disease can't pass through
them it can't infect those people so if
we do a sort of your standard
vaccination campaign which is basically
just that you kind of vaccinate people
at random you know anybody who comes in
and wants the vaccine you give it to
them well if you vaccinate people at
random then most of the people are going
to end up vaccinating are going to be
not the hub's right because the hubs are
only a tiny fraction of the population
almost everybody in the population is
just a regular person so if you've
accident use people at random you're
going to end up vaccinating regular
people not the hub's so here's an
example of a small network i vaccinate
this person and this person so they're
effectively knocked out of the network
so now the network looks like this but
it's still basically connected together
right the disease can still spread
through this network but now if we take
the alternative approach and we
vaccinate the hubs in the network we
deliberately look for the ones that have
many connections knock them out still
only the same number of people getting
vaccinated but now we've completely
disconnected the network and now the
disease can't spread so this leads us to
this idea of targeted vaccinations if we
can only find the right people to
vaccinate the right way of attacking
this network then we can be very
effective at controlling the spread of
disease with actually surprisingly
little effort we don't need to vaccinate
that many people in order to prevent the
disease from spreading this kind of
target attack on network can be
extremely effective if we take real data
for a typical social network and then
simulate the spread of a disease can do
a computer simulation to spread a
disease
we find that you'd need to vaccinate
about 95% of everybody in order to knock
out enough knows that the disease can't
spread anymore on the other hand if you
simply target the nodes that have the
highest degrees the hub's in the network
then you only need to remove about 20%
of them much more effective so you you'd
have to make much less effort and
take take much less vaccine and you can
still prevent the spread of the disease
this effect is called herd immunity
that's the name that is an
epidemiologist give to the idea that
your you can immunize a small fraction
and that effectively gives them you
energy to everybody else however there
is a catch here and the catch is how do
we find these people with the highest
degrees because we don't have a map of
the social network you know there's no
map of the social network of Singapore
where you can just go and look them up
and pick them out of a map oh look this
person there's a lot of people this
person there's a lot of people well
there are various ways one could do this
but one particularly nice suggestion
that I like is that we can use the
network itself to find the people with
many connections this idea was put
forward by Reuben Cohen and Shlomo
havlin they call it acquaintances
immunization and it works as follows
so in your typical vaccination campaign
you just choose people at random and you
vaccinate them and that doesn't work
very well in their suggested way of
doing this acquaintance immunization you
choose people at random but then you
don't vaccinate them instead you ask
them to name one of their friends and
you go find that friend and you
vaccinate them instead so this sounds
like a crazy idea but actually it's not
actually it's really smart because if
you think about it suppose someone has a
thousand friends then they have a
thousand opportunities to be nominated
by one of their friends as the person
who should get vaccinated person only
has one friend and here one opportunity
to be nominated so the people who have
lots of friends are much more likely to
get vaccinated in the scheme and the
people who don't so it's doing exactly
the right thing
it's vaccinating the high degree people
and leaving the low degree people alone
so they did simulations of this on a
computer you know simulate the spread of
disease over a computer and it turns out
that this is actually an extremely
effective way of doing it with a lot
less work a lot few vaccinations you can
prevent the disease from spreading as
far as I know this has not yet been
tried out in practice with a real
disease but maybe it should be maybe
this will be better than the kind of
things we're doing at the moment
okay so so this so this is a particular
example of what I would call resilience
or robustness of a network so the
crucial question here is how resilient
or robust is this network to this attack
we're attacking it by vaccinating some
of the nose to remove them from the
network and in this particular case we
want the network to be not very robust
but there are other cases where we would
like networks to be robust take the
internet for example we want the
internet to work now there are nodes
that fail on the internet all the time
this is a regular occurrence but we
would like to engineer it in such a way
that when that happens then network
still functions pretty well and you can
still you know get to your favorite web
site at whatever it is so there are some
networks we'd like them to be robust in
there are some networks like this one
we'd like them to be not robust but
actually kind of the same mathematics
applies to both cases and this is a big
topic of study currently in network
theory so an interesting question here
is what is it about networks that makes
them robust or not robust can we tell by
looking at the structure of network
whether it's going to be robust there
are various different things that affect
this robustness of networks but one
interesting one is something that we
already saw if you were here at
yesterday's lecture and that's this idea
of her muffle II remember this picture
from yesterday which is a picture of
friendships between school students in a
u.s. high school and what we saw is
though the way the black and white nodes
are the black and white kids in the
school and mostly the white kids are
friends with other white kids and the
black kids are friends with other black
kids they tend to be friends with people
of the same ethnic group as them so this
is the effect that we call term awfully
similar nodes connect this together I
want to talk about another variation on
this idea I'm awfully by degree this is
okay this is kind of getting
sophisticated now we're going to combine
two of our network theory ideas together
to make a combined idea this idea from
awfully knows light to be connected
other nodes that are the same as them
and the idea of degree how many
connections do you have her mostly by
degree means that knows what a lot of
connections like to connect to other
nodes that have a lot of connections
so the gregarious people are hanging out
with
gregarious people in the hermit's are
hanging out with other Hermits okay here
is an example of looking at that from a
paper by some folks about 10 years ago
what this plot shows this is Internet
data and the horizontal axis is number
of connections degree number of
connections that note on the internet
have vertical axis is how many
connections to your neighbors have so
what this is showing is that if you have
very few connections you're down here
then your note neighbors have a lot
whereas if you have a lot of connections
you're out here then your neighbors have
very few so this is actually sort of an
T homophily I guess Petr awfully would
be the correct word this is actually the
the party people hanging out with the
hermit's and the hermit's hanging all
the party people not the other way
around but you can get both of these
things in fact here's some simple
measurements so one thing that we came
up with it was just a simple number a
correlation coefficient that tells you
whether tells you which way it's working
all the high degree nodes connected to
other high degree nodes or they connect
to the low degree nodes this number here
is going to be positive if it's party
people hanging out with other party
people and it's going to be negative
it's if it's party people hanging out
with Herrmann's so here's the internet
for example and you see a negative
number that's what we just saw the high
degree nodes are connected to the low
degree nodes and vice-versa
these ones at the top are all social
networks they all have positive numbers
so the party people are hanging out with
the party people in in that case there's
an interesting split between these two
all the social networks it's always
positive it's always people with a lot
of friends hang out with other people a
lot of friends Hermits hanging out with
other Hermits in all the other networks
we've looked at the internet worldwide
where biological networks and so forth
it's the reverse the Hydra we know is
connected to the load of good notes why
do I care about this well it turns out
that this has a big effect on the
structure of networks here's what
happens if it's positive in other words
if it's the party people hanging out
with other party people you get a
network that looks like this this is not
a real network I just generated this one
on my computer to give you an idea what
it looks like you get this sort of dense
score all the party people are connected
to other party
people so you get this dense core of
people all connected together who have a
lot of connections and then you get this
thinner sort of periphery around the
edge which is the people who don't have
so many connections on the other hand in
the negative case the party people are
hanging out with the Hermit so you get
these sort of star like structures see
here's a party person and there's all
the Hermits that they're hanging out
with ok so what this means now is that
the party people the high degree nodes
and now strewn all over the network
they're not concentrated in a group in
the middle in the core like they were
they now spread out all over the network
because they don't want to be connected
together anymore so you get quite
different structures for these two
networks and it turns out that this has
a big effect on the resilience of the
network now suppose we want to vaccinate
people against the spread of a disease
so we're talking about a social network
social networks are over here on the
left hand side they have the positive
numbers the high degree nodes connects
to other high degree nodes if we so we
want to vaccinate the people that have
the most connections so we vaccinate a
bunch of people who have lots of
connections but all of those people are
concentrated here in the middle of the
network in the core in this particular
case so what we'd end up doing is just
vaccinating people here in the core and
we'd so effectively cut a little hole
out of the middle of the network but the
rest of the network around it would
still be just fine so in this case this
is actually not an effective strategy
for vaccinating another way of saying
that is that this network is very robust
against that particular attack that
particular way of vaccinating community
this is bad news because this is social
networks over here on the positive side
we want the social networks to not be
robust but actually it turns out they
are robust over here on the other side
we have things like the internet the
negative ones but now these ones turn
out to be very fragile because their
high degree nodes are spread all over
the place
knock those out and you've knocked out
all the crucial centers all over the
network and the network falls apart very
quickly so we actually have exactly the
opposite of what we'd like to have this
kind of bad news picture really the
social networks it turns out are very
robust against these kinds of attacks
and the internet is very fragile against
them we'd like this one to be robust and
this one to be fragile but it's the
wrong way
so I've just got a few minutes left
in the last few minutes what I'd like to
do is just tell you about a few of the
things that people have done with this I
these ideas of using networks to
understand the spread of disease this
has now become a big industry this is an
important topic a lot of people
interested in and people have done some
very sophisticated things towards
understanding how the structure of
networks affects the spread of these one
example is actually a local example here
in New Mexico something called epi Sims
which was created by people working at
los alamos whatever Sims does is it's a
simulation of an entire city in fact
it's a simulation of the entire city of
Portland Oregon it includes every person
every vehicle moving along the roads the
entire road plan of the city every
building in the city
it's an incredibly detailed micro
simulation that incorporates all the
things that are going on in the city and
then they use the city this simulated
city to simulate the spread of a disease
so what they do is they started C
spreading somewhere in the city and and
you know they actually follow all the
individual people moving around they go
to work or they go to school or they go
into whatever they do and who catch the
disease from whom and they're able to
predict in great detail how the disease
is going to spread through the city one
of the nice things about this is that
they can now change anything they like
about it
you know let's say we have you know a
curfew let's say we vaccinate this half
of the population let's say a bunch of
people leave town you can just try all
of those things in your simulation and
see what effect it has on the spread of
the disease so the idea behind these
kinds of very detailed studies is that
it enables us to try a lot of different
experiments about what a good strategies
for controlling the spread of disease
before it actually happens you don't
want to be experimenting with different
strategies while an outbreak is actually
going on this allows you to just do it
on the computer
try various different things and work
out what's most likely to work there's
no claim of course that this is an exact
representation of the world but they've
done a lot of work to make it as
accurate as they possibly can this is
the spread of disease on a relatively
small scale the scale of a single city
there have also been studies done where
people look at much larger scales if
you're looking at the spread of disease
over the whole world then it turns out
that the crucial factor in the spread of
disease is airline traffic it's people
getting on airplanes who are sick and
flying to other places and when they get
there they give the disease to somebody
else airline flights are the primary
vector for carrying diseases around the
world airlines are basically just big
metal tubes flying through the air full
of germs carrying them to other places
so they do so this is from work by
Vittorio Kalia and colleagues that
Indiana University they have simulations
of individual cities and then they have
the complete map of all the airline
flights going on in the entire world
when those flights take place how many
people on average fly on each of those
flights every day and then they do a big
computer simulation they say suppose we
have an epidemic starting for instance
like SARS did in Southeast Asia and they
can predict when that disease is going
to get to some other country some other
city they can predict how bad it's going
to be when it gets there how long it's
going to take and so forth so these
kinds of simulations now allow us to
make really quite detailed predictions
about the large-scale spread of disease
they actually did some predictions about
the spread of flu they predicted how
long it would take one year's flu to get
to various different countries and then
after the fact after that year's flu
outbreak they went back and compared
their predictions to what to what
actually happened in the real world and
it turned out they actually did pretty
well of course they didn't get
everything right but it was actually
surprisingly accurate so I think there's
good
signs that these kinds of techniques
could be very useful you could do
exactly the same things with this as you
did with the Portland study you could
try out different techniques for
preventing the disease for spreading
what happens if we vaccinate all of
these people and so forth you can try
different things before it happens and
work out what's going to be a good
strategy for preventing the spread of
disease so I'm very nearly out of time
really the last thing I want to do is
just point out that all of this stuff
that I've talked about in the last three
lectures is in many ways just the
beginnings of the field we haven't been
working on that this long on this that
long and there are many things that we
still don't know we would certainly like
to get better at measuring networks we
don't like to understand how they change
over time the kinds of things I've been
talking about today understand how a
changing network can change its
performance you know if we if we reroute
the network if we change it in some way
how will it affect the behavior we'd
like to get better at predicting Network
phenomena the kind of things that I
talked about yesterday predict how a
society will react to something
happening we'd like to be able to
prevent disease outbreaks by knowing
what the best strategy is for
vaccination and so forth these are all
good questions but there are many many
more that I haven't had time to talk
about of course the things that I've
been able to tell you about are only a
small portion of this whole subject
there are now thousands of people
working in this area of network theory
an awful lot of interesting work it's a
very active area but I hope that I've
given you a flavor for the sort of
things that we're interested in I'd like
to say thank you very much to all of you
for coming here it's it's been a
pleasure I'd be happy to answer
questions if you've got them and thanks
for your attention
yeah question down the front here there
are two parameters yeah so one is the
average number of citations that the
paper makes I mean how many do you cite
which is something that you can measure
in the data and the other one is is
slightly more complicated so there's a
catch here which I didn't mention which
is that if the number of citations you
get is proportionate number you already
have well when your papers first publish
you don't have any yet so you wouldn't
get in so that means no paper would ever
get any because they all have 0 when
they start so there's kind of a catch
there so there's little Cluj there what
he did was he said well we'll make it
not actually proportional but it's
proportional to number you have plus
some other number of free citations so
there's another parameter there which
basically what it represents is how fast
is the paper get cited when it's never
had any citations in the past and that
that parameter in principle could be
dependent on the quality of the paper
for instance it's something which could
be higher for good papers and bad papers
so there are those two parameters in
there and what I did in those
calculations that I showed you is I
started by I got the values of the
parameters by fitting it to the overall
distributions of citations and then he
used the same values to predict that
first-mover effect so although there are
two parameters in that calculation it's
effectively a 0 parameter fit because
I've already fitted the parameters to
the overall distribution so sort of yes
and no is the answer question yes
so a good question so yes I admit I have
looked to see how many people have cited
my papers and and yes absolutely it
seems to be true of my papers well so I
so within physics it is correct that I
was one of the first people to get into
this subject and I think that I've
certainly benefited from that so yeah
maybe I'm and I think perhaps I'm not
very good at this stuff at all I just
happened to be there first right
yeah so good questions the question is
do do non-infectious diseases also have
network effects and and so yeah I think
so too things like it's just one is for
hereditary diseases then there is still
a network in play and it's basically the
genealogical network it's the network of
who's descended from whom and certainly
there are network effects there the
other is though even with things like
obesity and alcoholism there which a
that there are there are indications
that those are socially transmitted so
there's a series of very interesting
studies by James Fowler and Nicholas
Christakis where they had social network
data and they had data on things like
obesity smoking alcoholism stuff like
that and they found that people were
much more likely to be extremely
overweight if they had friends that were
extremely overweight and so forth so
there is some evidence I'd have to say
that evidence is still somewhat
controversial not everybody accepts the
results but certainly this is something
people are interested in you know it
seems like a reasonable idea that
obesity is something where you know if
if if your friends all eat too much then
maybe you eat too much as well I mean it
doesn't seem an unreasonable idea that
this could be a socially transmitted
condition so yes absolutely people are
looking at that yes
absolutely yes so basically if the curve
is flatter meaning that there are more
hubs out there then it tends to be more
fragile if if if there are hubs out
there which really have a lot of
connections you know huge numbers of
connections then removing just one of
those is very devastating for the
network whereas if the curve is steeper
and the highest-degree hubs don't have
that many connections then removing them
still important but it doesn't have
quite such a big effect so absolutely
you're correct it certainly depends
quite strongly on sort of what the slope
of that curve is yes another question
down there what do you mean by context
can you give an example
okay so yes so very good
so absolutely those things do affect
things like the spread of disease there
are some there are many good non network
reasons why things like poverty affect
the spread of disease people have poorer
health care and so forth poorer
education but there can also be Network
effects there because people who are in
different situations also have
differently structured networks so one
of the things that you notice for
instance is that poorer people tend to
have more geographically local networks
and rich people tend to you know fly on
airplanes engines all over the place so
then networks are more spread out and
this can have a big effect on the spread
of disease actually that in a mostly
local network diseases will spread
mostly locally in a disease with these
long range connections disease can
spread very quickly to places far away
there's actually an interesting contrast
to be drawn here between modern-day
networks where the transmission of
disease is dominated as I said by
airline flight people getting on
airplanes and taking diseases of
different places and what happened
centuries ago before we had long-range
travel if you look at something like the
Black Death in the 14th century which
was a form of hemorrhagic fever there
was a big outbreak of it in Europe
starting in 1347 it actually arrived in
Europe first in Constantinople and then
spread along the Mediterranean I mean
trade ships and then moved northwards
through Europe and I've seen maps of
this where the disease there were the
sort of contours every six months the
disease is just advancing a certain
distance so it's moving geographically
and that and the reason for that is that
people in those days only knew the other
people who lived geographically close to
them nowadays you see this long range
transmission where you know a disease
can start in Singapore and within a week
it can be in Toronto in those days it's
very clear that it was sort of this
geographical transmission where it just
moved it was a couple of hundred miles
every six months so a completely
different kind of transmission of the
disease indicating a completely
different underlying structure of the
network over which the disease is being
transmitted yes question there
so absolutely not first forth so so what
I'm saying is that with things like that
there'll be this preferential attachment
law it appears that the important thing
is to get that early lead and there are
various things that can get you an early
lead one of them of course is just
writing a paper that's really good and
everybody takes notice but another one
for instance is getting your paper
published in a high-profile journal some
something that people take notice of and
that's of course a part of this peer
review process the you know referees can
say no this paper is suitable for a
better journal or a less good journal
and that's one of the things that
certainly affects how much people notice
so it I mean it's certainly true that
all the various things to do with the
quality and content of a paper play into
how well it will get referenced but
they're mostly playing into it via the
question of whether it gets this early
lead because really once you've
established the beginning is this a
paper that's going to get cited or not
get cited after that this preferential
attachment thinks it seems to take over
and just amplifies whatever you started
off with
yes question back there
right
so that particular study that was done
by Kalia and collaborators was a study
of SARS and so they the SARS outbreak in
2003 started in southern China so they
chose that as the sort of epicenter for
that particular simulation and and then
we're trying to predict you know how the
disease would have spread from there and
they compared their predictions against
what happened in the actual SARS
outbreak
for instance when it came to North
America it particularly affected Toronto
and Vancouver and so they wanted to sort
of compare that they did that
deliberately so they can see how well
their simulation method was working
compared to what the real SARS did
however it's absolutely the case that's
if it were some other disease that we
were thinking of then it might start in
some other part of the world they
certainly haven't done studies for every
other possible starting place but it's
exactly the sort of thing that you would
want to do if you want to understand how
a disease starting one kick place can
reach other places yes question
I mean crazy creative network somehow
yeah so possibly I mean so there
certainly have been many advances in
recent years where people have created
networks between people that didn't
exist before I mean the ones that get
the most publicity of course online
things but there's no reason in
principle why you can't go about
creating networks like this of course
social engineering of that kind is a
tremendously difficult topic it's not
something that we understand how to do
well sometimes people try to engineer a
network and it fails miserably and other
times they don't really know what
they're doing and yet it's a wild
success we haven't learned yet how to
make this these things predictably work
well but but certainly you know this is
the kind of thing that people have tried
in the past and sometimes it works so so
in principle it's possible but I think
that there's a big gap in our knowledge
there about exactly how you go about
doing that maybe one more question yes a
question over there
uh-huh
yeah that's that's a good question so as
far as I know no they haven't in
particular actually I don't think that
was something they considered when they
did that airline simulation study the
way that worked was you know there were
people in the city and some of them had
the disease and then they flew to the
other city and gave it to other people
in the city but you're absolutely right
now you mention it I've had the same
experience I think that you know
airplanes are pretty bad places for
catching the flu from other people and
stuff like that
yo yo yo hope you're stuck in this
little box in the sky for several hours
with a bunch of other people and you
know circulating air and so forth
so so yeah you're right I wouldn't be
that surprised if that was an important
vector for the spread of disease and I
actually haven't seen that considering
these studies so maybe that's an element
that's missing from them at the moment
okay I think you've done a brilliant job
nodding and giving a lecture but in
fielding the questions and responding so
let's give Marc a very hefty hand for
the cleaner